-Last week, in a shocking
and sadly predictable move,
the Supreme Court overturned
Roe v Wade.
I was angered,
saddened by the news.
And before we get started,
I just want to be clear
that abortion
is not only a women's issue,
it's not only
a pregnant person's issue.
It's everyone's issue.
We all benefit
from reproductive freedom
and from access to legal
and safe abortions.
I think it's possible that men
hear, "My body, my choice,"
and we take away the message
that it's not our issue
to speak about,
but it's everyone's job
to advocate
for reproductive rights.
So I asked my writers, Amber,
Jenny, and Ally,
what I can do to help
and they said,
"You can start by shutting up."
-That's right. We did.
-Okay.
Okay.
Because, you know,
if something like this happens,
we should center
the voices of people
who are most affected by it.
-We said to shut up.
-Okay.
-We are devastated
and disappointed
in our country right now.
We're joke writers,
but we didn't want
to come out here tonight
and tell jokes or do goofy bits
that didn't feel right.
-Instead, we could
share our feelings.
-We could talk to an expert
on reproductive rights.
-Or we could burn it
all to the ground.
-But -- But we're not going
to do that.
We're going to do
the second one.
So please welcome the president
and CEO of Planned Parenthood
Federation of America,
Alexis McGill Johnson.
♪♪
-Alexis, thank you so much
for being here,
especially on today of all days.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
Look, it's just not an honor.
I really appreciated
your opening and saying that we
all have a stake in this fight,
and I'm just grateful to be here
in this conversation with you.
-Alexis, we wanted to
ask you some questions.
First off, what does
this Supreme Court decision
mean for Americans?
-You know, what the
Supreme Court did on Friday
is essentially tell us
that half the population
is not free and equal,
right?
26 states will be moving very
quickly in the next few weeks
to few months
to ban access to abortion
or severely restrict it,
meaning that if you live
in one state
like New York or California,
you will be free and equal.
And if you live in a state like
Texas or Oklahoma or Missouri,
it may be that you won't
have access
to the care that you need.
That would affect upwards
of 36 million people, right?
And we've already seen
a little bit
of what that looks like,
because we are living
in a post-Roe world
in states like Texas
and Oklahoma.
We're seeing people
having to get in their cars
and drive thousands
of miles out of state
just to get access to care.
We are seeing people
who can't get out of state
for many horrible reasons,
and they're essentially
being forced into pregnancy.
And, you know, it just means
that, you know,
that freedom is something --
it's a practice.
We have to continue to fight
for it over and over again.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've heard a lot of people say
that this ruling
is not just about abortion.
Can you explain what that means?
-Yeah, absolutely. It goes
far beyond abortion, right?
I mean, you know,
first we have to ask, you know,
in some of these states --
I don't know if you've seen
kind of what the restrictions
look like, right?
Some of them are banning access
to abortion after fertilization.
You know, Texas has a six-week
ban, which is after -- you know,
before actually many people
know that they are pregnant.
But we've also seen
introductions of laws
in states like Missouri
that are trying to ban moving
across state lines
to get access to care.
We've seen states like Louisiana
that are banning access to IVF
and IUDs
and emergency contraception,
Plan B, right?
They're introducing these laws
that are so incredibly,
you know, extreme.
And so when we talk about
the kind of notion of like,
this is just about abortion,
it is really about control
over our own bodies.
When you look
at the way the law --
the opinions are written,
you know, there are also
kind of indications
that there are
other opportunities to go
after things
like marriage equality,
like interracial marriage,
you know, like access
to contraception,
all of which has enjoyed
federal protections
as well, constitutional
protections.
And that's where we really need
to be concerned
of overreach here.
-So what are you hearing
from your patients right now?
-Just devastation, right?
I mean, the ruling
came down on Friday
when we had patients who were,
you know,
making their way to the clinic.
And, you know, we all thought
that the decision
would come down
sometime this week, right?
Which would be
the full end of the term,
which meant that we were rushing
to get as many patients in
to be seen as possible.
They are scared.
They are confused.
They are worried
about criminalization
because we don't know
what the other spate of laws
is going to look like, right?
We don't know
how they're going to enforce
the other abortion bans
that they are going
to put in place.
And they're concerned, you know.
Most people who seek access
to abortion care
are already parents,
so they're worried about,
you know,
how to take care
of their families
and how to ensure that they have
what they need to move forward
for their own,
you know, self-determination.
So, you know,
we're trying to reassure them.
There is a website
called AbortionFinder.org
that we have, you know,
connected to with
an organization called
Power To Decide, where people
can find access to appointments.
But the reality is,
you know, 24 states,
you know, just can't absorb
the nation's care, right?
So we're looking at a health
care crisis coming upon us.
-Alexis, what role does sex
education play in all of this?
-Oh, I mean, sex education
is everything, right?
I mean, in order
to control your body,
you have to understand
how it works. Right?
In order to advocate
for your body and your freedoms,
you have to understand kind of
how your body works
and what that looks like.
I think it's one
of the many tools
that we have to essentially
raise this next new generation
to understand
kind of what's at stake.
The states that don't
teach sex ed, for example --
the states that are
abstinence-only -- are states
where we see higher rates
of unintended pregnancies
because of course, people don't
know how to control them, right?
So I think that all of the ways
in which we think
about how our bodies,
how our gender,
how our sexuality,
how our race intersects with
our kind of our own advocacy
is the opportunity
that we have to kind of raise
a new, different generation.
-So I have a question
from the perspective of men,
and I know there are many of us
who support this issue.
We aren't exactly sure
the best way to show it --
how -- what is the best,
the most effective way to show
that we're allies in this fight?
-Well, look, a good ally
is an active ally,
not a passive ally, right?
You're a great ally right now,
kind of centering
this conversation
as the opening of the show.
And it's important
for men to talk about
what's happening
and what's at stake, right?
You're, you know, also affected
by the impact to abortion.
You're also hurt by patriarchy.
You're also hurt by misogyny.
And I think it's kind
of actually sexy
when people support
reproductive rights.
I don't know about you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So we've all had a few days
to be very, very angry now.
And I -- But if we want to move
from anger to action,
what can we do?
-Well, look,
I think we all started off
incredibly sad and devastated,
and that devastation
turned very quickly
into that rage,
right, where we have to channel
that right now into action.
It is really important right now
if you want to care for patients
and get patients to care,
support your local
Planned Parenthood organization.
Support independent clinics
in those states
that are going to see
abortion bans be restricted --
abortion be restricted.
You can go to KeepOurClinics.org
to support them.
You can go to AbortionFunds.org,
which are resources
that help get patients --
you know, it's travel money,
gas money.
You know, just to get out of
state is critically important.
You can share
about your fight for access
by going to #BansOffOurBodies
to find places
that will be a place
to update you around all of
the things that are going on.
And then of course, you can
share your own stories,
right, at #WhateverTheReason,
because part of why this
conversation is so important
is because of stigma, right?
We are here
because we have stigmatized
a very normal procedure,
one that one in four women
in their life
will have an abortion,
and the fact that we have
stigmatized --
the fact that we don't talk
about it means
that people can make policies
that codify our inequality.
And if we want to stay free, we
have to talk about our freedom
and we have to ensure
that people understand
what is critically
important here.
-Alexis, we cannot
thank you enough
for being with us here tonight.
I also want to thank Amber,
Jenny, and Ally
for being here
and helping us out.
And we're going to be right back
with more "Late Night."
[ Cheers and applause ]